don't feel bad if you don't know the
name Robby ray is his storyline is
literally called the all-new Ghost Rider
he was first written in 2014 that is
really new compared to the 40 years
since Johnny Blaze first appeared riding
a flaming motorcycle Robby is an
eighteen year old high school student
and he's the full-time caretaker of his
disabled younger brother Gabe oh and he
kills people in the evenings while his
head is on fire Robby is a mechanic and
a street racer also he drives a 1969
Dodge Charger that's possessed by the
evil soul of his dead uncle he borrows
that charger to enter a street race to
win enough money to move Gabe into a
better neighborhood
unbeknownst to Robby the trunk of the
charger is filled with drugs a
paramilitary group comes to collect the
drugs as they do Robby is chased
executed and the car is set on fire also
as it turns out he didn't win the race
when Robby is murdered an evil spirit
who happens to be his uncle Eli binds
himself to Robbie's soul and to the
Dodge Charger turning them into an
unholy trinity of fire
400 horsepower and teenage hormones
Robby got in a fight with Johnny Blaze
the og Ghost Rider
and he get spin and stared hard pin and
stare works like this the worst your
soul is the worst the stare affects you
and with the spirit of a murderer
inhabiting your body that probably gets
uncomfortable apparently being possessed
by any satanic spirit lights your head
and vehicle on fire but only those
possessed by a spirit of vengeance gets
you into the ghost rider club
Robbie has cool ghostrider abilities
like hellfire chains and a flaming
vehicle but because his demonic uncle is
riding shotgun he gets control over
darkness and teleportation - oh and his
uncle eats everyone souls that they kill
because you know demons for more on your
favorite movies TV shows and comic books
check out GameSpot universe